et oui je vais vous parler du service
public parce que moi j'adore le service
public service public
car avec les doigts mais réfléchissez
cyr l'instant c'est quand même
formidable qu'on ait mis autant de
moyens ensemble pour organiser la vie
pour se déplacer pour se former pour se
protéger il ya plein de pays dans le
monde c'est pas le cas et des pays où
quand on tombe malade
eh bien on n'est pas sûr qu'on pourra
payer ses soins il ya des pays où il
n'ya pas de mode de garde pour les
petits-enfants et des pays où
l'université coûte tellement cher et que
on est pratiquement obligé de faire un
emprunt à la naissance des enfants si on
veut les y envoyer un jour voilà ici
c'est pas le cas parce qu'on a le
service public formidable voix près en
pratique je suis comme tout le monde à
moi aussi je passe mon temps à pester
contre le service public moi aussi je
trouve ça incroyable c'est obligé devant
une demi journée de congé pour la
moindre démarche aussi j'arrive pas à
remplir les bordereaux et puis je vous
parle pas des justificatifs mais qu'est
ce qui peut bien faire des justifie qu
est-ce qui peuvent y revient des
justificatifs
c'est à se demander non c'est fini tout
ça des fois même c'est c'est plus grave
que ça moi j'ai lu des courriers pour
des bénéficiaires d'être social il faut
un bac +5 en droit pour les comprendre
c'est obliger les gens peuvent pas
répondre après c'est comme ça qu'on crée
de la précarité
non c'est terrible ce qui est fou en
plus c'est que y'a aucune mauvaise
volonté derrière tout ça la personne
derrière le guichet la plupart du temps
elles vous veut du bien
et la personne qui écrit le courrier
bien être et du mieux qui peut aider et
hiérarchie aussi et c'est pas forcément
un besoin après d'argent non plus au
fond du fond moi ça fait 25 ans que je
travaille dans le service public
j'ai travaillé dans des collectivités
locales traille pour la sécu vous êtes
pour les bordereaux je vous en parle et
j'ai travaillé aussi dans une agence de
développement économique et je peux vous
dire le problème c'est que le service
public n'est pas pensé en fonction de
vos besoins
il est pensé en fonction des procédures
attention les procédures c'est quelque
chose d'important il ya des lois à
respecter
il ya des délais qu'il faut tenir il
faut faire attention c'est de l'argent
public donc il faut contrôler c'est
normal et puis souvent au départ les
procédures ça marche bien et puis un
jour la loi change alors on modifie la
procédure et puis un jour on fait du
contrôle non plus alors on met des
tableaux de bord mais les indicateurs et
puis la loi et rechange
et puis quelqu'un décide qu'il faut
associer d'autres personnes ont fait des
comités techniques etc et à la fin si
tout se passe bien
la procédure est tellement complexe que
quand il a fini
eh bien tu te souviens pas pourquoi tu
l'a commencée j'ai vécu ça plein de fois
dans la vie professionnelle par exemple
c'était en 2004 imaginer c'était juste
après les élections régionales et un
nouveau président de région dans son
dans ses promesses électorales y en
avait une importante c'était la gratuité
des manuels scolaires
voilà ce qu'il s'agit d'acheter des
livres pour les lycéens c'est simple en
fait dans les collèges
on paye pas ses livres dans les lycées
on les payait et 10 c les régions elle
s'occupait des églises ont rappelé les
livres et parce qu'il a envie que ça se
passe vite et parce qu'il veut montrer
d'eux c'est important il me demande à
moi qui suis à l'époque son directeur de
cabinet de m en occuper et là commence
le parcours d'obstacles d'abord il faut
trouver les crédits c'est plusieurs
millions d'euros 1 280 x et dans la
région
après il faut inscrire sa au budget
après il faut voir les gens c'est normal
on fait un tour avec tout le monde les
gens c'est donc le rectorat s'élancer
l'enseignement privé
c'est les syndicats de deux proviseurs
ces syndicats d'intendant ces syndicats
de personnels sont chacun le leur c'est
les fédérations de parents d'élèves avec
dans les fédérations de parents d'élèves
des gens qui sont contre à y ait des
gens qui veulent payer on veut p
je pas pourquoi et puis des lycéens
enfin c'est eux que ça regarde quand
même finalement et voilà donc on fait un
point avec eux on tombe d'accord et puis
derrière on rédige une délibération et
puis derrière on va la montrer aux
services juridiques pour que le service
juridique voix si c'est conforme et puis
après on va au service des marchés
publics
parce que eux aussi doit voir si tout va
bien et si on l'a bien fait les choses
voilà après on réunit tout le monde et
puis après enfin on passe au vote
alors il ya les votes dans les
commissions commission de la région
commission du conseil économique et
social régional parce que ça existe ça
aussi et puis après vote de ce même
conseil vote en assemblée plénière et
non c'est pas fini parce que après la
délibération une fois que c'est voter il
faut l'envoyer à la préfecture pour la
tutelle juridique par si tout va bien
et puis hop à oman au trésorier payeur
général pour payer voilà c'est fini
enfin c'est le circuit pour ça
parce qu'on peut faire plus long c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui nous est arrivé parce
qu'il ya une erreur dans les
délibérations
on avait commencé à faire quelque chose
qui faisait que le marché nous
obligeaient à acheter à une grande
centrale d'achat tous les livres et
comme ça on aurait on aurait planté
plein de libraires dans la région alors
on a été obligé de changer la
délibération au dernier moment
ce qui veut dire là que le parcours
d'obstacles se changent un peu en jeu de
l'oie vous voyez le jeu de l'oie il y en
a 15 58 salles où il ya la tête de mort
j'effectue repart au départ bah c'est ça
c'est ça qui arrive à la fin à la fin tu
es content 1 et un peu plus du rêve de
passer à autre chose
et d'ailleurs quand on arrête quand on
arrive dans mon bureau le les syndicats
de personnels qui nous y parlait mais
les livres ils vont être livrés en plein
mois d'août pour la rentrée de septembre
et ben on n'est pas là et puis ben ça
fait des milliers ouest pour ali stocker
et puis qui sait qui va les distribuer
moi je dis mais j'en sais rien moi pas
enfin nous on a fait toute la procédure
un savent à quoi bon en fait ça s'est
bien passé parce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
a fait des boulots et ça mais moi en
tout cas voilà voilà comment on part on
a plein d'idées à la gratuité de
l'enseignement l'éducation
l'émancipation et à la fin tu suis pas
procédure voilà mais ça c'est le
quotidien de l'administration la routine
tu commences bon fait à bloc
tu finis rincez et tu t'habitues dans le
pire c'est que tu t'habitues ou pas moi
en tout cas j'en ai eu marre je ne
pouvais plus j'ai craqué alors j'ai
provoqué mon grand bureau 70 m² et mon
assistant pas voiture de fonction pour
un bureau offrant un couloir de chargés
de mission et par contre mon boulot il
était super mon boulot c'était de
trouver des nouvelles idées des
nouvelles méthodes pour les élus et pour
les directeurs de la région j'étais
agitateurs officiel quoi punk à chien ou
un truc comme ça
et donc il est très vite dans ce que
j'ai fait j'ai rencontré des gens c'est
la 27e région avant de cette même région
c'est une association qui est précurseur
dans l'innovation publique est là depuis
dix ans transformé plein
d'administration partout en france et
d'ailleurs elle a essaimé un peu partout
elle a fait des petits d'ailleurs moi
moi même je je suis un peu petit
et j'utilise pour changer là pour
changer de l'administration il utilise
le design centré sur l'utilisateur
ouais le design comme dans l'entreprise
je vais essayer de vous montrer oui ça
c'est la télécommande à ma mamie alors
et elle a plein de boutons qu'elle sait
pas quoi en faire
alors elle a mis du sparadrap dessus
le truc c'est censé être utile en fait l
on a peur non c'est fou et après en plus
il ya plein d'autres choses qu'on peut
voir sur une télécommande
alors c'est moche alors que ça doit être
dans le salon dont vu que c'est moche
mais les planques vue pour les plans
qu'on y retrouve pas quand on en a
besoin
ah ouais voilà ça c'est une télécommande
qui est pas bien pensée et bien le
design centré utilisateurs ça a vocation
à prendre ses observations pour les
transformer en meilleur service voilà
bien une petite start up de nantes qui
s'appelle forme haute technologie qui a
fait ce travail sans les voir manny puis
deux trois autres puis d'autres gens
aussi et puis ils ont repensé la
télécommande
voilà voyez elle est jolie et jolie
vraiment on comprend à quoi elle sert
les boutons n'y en a pas beaucoup
elle est allée ergonomique et il ya même
un bouton qui est là quand on appuie
dessus on lui dit est ce que tu peux me
trouver un épisode de derrick s'il te
plaît d'éric faye pour mamie ans mais ça
marche avec game of thrones
eh ben il le donne et ça apparaît à la
télé et même à ça c'est un proto mais
après ça fera souris dans l'espace dont
pourra faire naviguer sur internet
directement avec ça ça permettra de le
faire non c'est vraiment bien cette
télécommande c'est comme il ya dix ans
avec le smartphone de qui vous savez où
comme il ya 25 ans avec l'aspirateur là
bas il n'y a pas de sac et ben ça va
changer ça va changer le monde des
télécommandes et sa grâce à des
observations qu'on a transformé en
fonctionnalités on fait ça dans le
secteur public il ya une petite
différence
cette différence c'est que là c'est un
acteur extérieur caraïbes épi qui
bouleverse tôt alors que bain dans le
secteur public c'est pas possible
l'autorité pour changer les choses c'est
l'administration et ses chefs qui les a
alors on ne peut pas on peut pas faire
sans eux c'est eux qu'on est obligé de
changer
en langage de start up on dirait on peut
pas disrupt et on mr bah ouais enfin
c'est lui qui doit quoi bon alors gare
gare est bien une discussion mais c'est
une fois tous les 6 ans et les élections
et bon voilà c'est ce qu'on fait alors
moi j'ai voulu vous faire une
présentation un petit peu sérieuse de ce
que c'est donc j'ai demandé à pouvoir
avoir le matériel pour réaliser une
réalisé une si tu ce que ça peut
représenter que le design centré
utilisateurs alors pour ça je demande et
vous allez voir c'est une très
technologique la meilleure façon de
construire une bonne politique publique
consiste en premier lieu à s'asseoir et
regarder les choses alors ça marche
aussi avec un bon mais par contre il
faut que ça soit sur place ça soit à la
médiathèque s'assoit au self ça soit
l'accueil de service public c'est secret
numéro un c'est il faut sortir de ton
bureau
alors là tu regardes tu sois un carnet
tu regardes qui est là qui est pas là
comment ça se passe et puis très vite il
ya des choses qui viennent
tu dis tiens c'est marrant enfin j'ai
pas dit non mais la dame avec son sens
avec sa poussette là elle a réussi à
rentrer dans l'accueil mais elle a du
mal à sortir
c'est un accueil petite enfance est pas
possible ou alors mais la motion il
vient juste prendre trois livres
pourquoi on lui demande tous ses papiers
ses fins a aucun sens où on tient dans
le self là plutôt que de mettre les
gâteaux de vente paraît pas mettre des
fruits qu'ils mangeraient moins de
cochonneries
voilà c'est des choses qu'on voit comme
ça et c'est plein de choses comme ça qui
permettent de d'avoir eu d'autres idées
c'est quelque chose qui demande en plus
d'une une chaise il faut aussi deux
autres éléments il faut de la curiosité
c'est aussi quelque chose qu'il faut
aller chercher et et de la bienveillance
on n'est pas là pour fliquer les agents
de service public non non on est là pour
comprendre ça laisse la place à
l'incertitude on va dire jeu comme ça
des collègues dans le département de
loire-atlantique qui avait réussi à à
dire un vice président aux transports
vient on va prendre du caractère urbain
comme ça tu voir comment ça se passe
avec les usagers et tout est donc il en
a fait 2 3 et puis le matin le matin où
on prenait le car à 6 heures pour rendre
se rendre à nantes
eh ben le car il n'est pas passé
alors les collègues n'étaient pas très
rassuré mais en même temps le vice
président il ya eu une vraie
observations il a vu les gens cap et
leurs employeurs pour leur dire qu'ils
seraient en retard les gens qui essaient
de trouver une voiture pour finalement
se rendre quand même à nantes puis les
gens qui rentraient comme ça en violant
il a vu la vraie vie et d'ailleurs nous
à la région on n'avait ni un nom pour ce
type de pratique on appelait ça le rer
le retour en réalité parce qu'en fait
quand on a vécu ça quand on rentre dans
son bureau on doit prendre des décisions
ben on pense à la procédure bien sûr
mais surtout aussi on pense aux gens qui
a derrière et au quartier passe pas
l'étape d'après c'est mettre vraiment
les gens dans la procédure
comme ça on est sûr de ne pas les
oublier s'appelle la co-construction
vous avez certainement entendu parler de
ça c'est normalement dans une
administration quand on change les
choses
ce qu'on fait c'est que l'on demande à
un cabinet conseil de nous aider alors
le cabinet conseil il va faire 10
interviews de joueurs importants et
c'est tout ça et après il va dans sa
grande armoire à solution c'est qu'ils
ont des grandes armoires solution et il
en prend ils en prennent une voix il a
modifié un petit peu quand même
puis il nous l'a donnée pour se
débrouiller avec des fois ça marche des
fois nous ce qu'on fait pour savoir ce
que veulent les gens parce qu'on leur
demande c'est un truc de ouf c'est
secret numéro 2 on l'a on leur parle
voilà et ça marche toujours très bien
quand les gens sont on s'intéresse à eux
et pas très simplement ou d'ailleurs
même si c'est difficile on peut le faire
quand même
je vous donne un exemple la ville de
nantes là elle a décidé de voir ce que
donnait ses activités périscolaires et
après l'école est donc plutôt que de
demander aux parents qui savent pas du
tout ce qui se passe au fond
eh ben ils ont demandé aux enfants sauf
qu'on peut pas arriver comme ça et dire
aux enfants
bonjour jeunes des écoles
l'un service éducation de la ville de
nantes souhaiteraient procéder à une
évaluation de la politique publique
périscolaire est ce que tu peux nous
aider le petit va dire ben donc voilà
ils ont pris des professionnels de
l'innovation publique
ils ont travaillé ils ont trouvé les
motifs à l'employé ils ont inventé des
jeux ils ont inventé des ateliers dessin
puis à la fin la vie donnant elle avait
tout ce qu'il voulait et ça on peut le
faire on y compris avec des adultes
parce qu'il ya les adultes des fois ils
n'ont pas d'idées des fois on vous
demande des trucs vous savez pas de quoi
répondre
moi je me suis retrouvé à demander
qu'est ce que vous pensez de 2040 à des
gens dans quel état serait on ne nous
répondent pas quoi donc voilà c'est pour
ça qu'il faut du design c'est pour ça
qu'il faut dire qu'il faut de la
sociologie pour arriver à inventer
inventer des façons d'obtenir des gens
plein de choses et à partir de ça on
peut réinventer l'action publique
c'est comme c'est comme avec la
télécommande après il ya eu des
ingénieurs ont travaillé mais en
attendant c'est à partir des
observations qui ont été faites que
derrière on a transformé en solution
qu'ont à prototyper qu'on a testé qu'on
a réussi quelque chose
voilà ça c'est la co-construction ça
permet beaucoup de choses dans ce pays
de nouvelles de nouveau et c'est hyper
important que de se dire que ça ça
permet de trouver des nouvelles
solutions
vous allez avec la crise on a besoin de
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses
nouvelles et on a besoin de chercheurs
on a besoin d'experts mais auprès des
usagers
on a plein plein plein plein de choses à
apprendre et on sait le faire donc il
faut pas avoir peur de le dire
voilà donc la prochaine fois que vous
verrez un panneau sur une piste cyclable
et bien vous serez quoi faire si vous
voulez pas monter un collectif pour dire
non aux panneaux sur les pistes
cyclables ou si vous voulez pas vous
présenter sur une liste non c'est pas
possible pour les pistes cyclables aux
élections d'après hé bien il vous reste
à dire votre mère que par l'innovation
publique ça existe par contre je vous
souhaite prendre trois vrais risques le
premier
qu'ils prennent du plaisir parce que
c'est simple allez rencontrer des gens
sur le terrain parler d'un côté être
dans son bureau lire des notes ou aller
à des réunions de l'autre une des deux
solutions est intéressante
saurez-vous les reconnaître la deuxième
chose c'est qu'ils risquent de faire
bien plus vite moins cher et mieux parce
que va faire avec les gens ne restent
pas d'art besoin de recommencer juste
derrière chose d'important mais surtout
surtout le dernier point c'est que ça
risque de redonner du sens à son action
parce que à mettre les usagers au coeur
des politiques publiques
eh ben on lutte contre le poison lent de
la procédure
à la fin on se souvient toujours de quel
est le but et le but qu'ils s'agissent
de sécurité sociale qu'il s'agisse de
panneaux sur les pistes cyclables qu'ils
s'agissent tu de mode de garde pour les
enfants c'est toujours un peu le même
c'est de rendre le meilleur service
possible à tous quels que soient nos
conditions quelles que soient nos
opinions
quelles que soient nos revenus ça
s'appelle la solidarité c'est le ciment
de la société française et je trouve
qu'en ce moment on en a plutôt besoin
merci